[Music]
hello everyone Perry back you're with
another exclusive Collider interview at
San Diego comic-con 2019 this is a very
exciting one because I've got the team
behind the new Dark Crystal Series right
here I I still can't believe this is
happening it's mind-boggling to me and
I'm so excited to see some footage to
start here I wanted to ask you too how
long you've been with this iteration of
the project cuz I know that it
originally started as a computer
generated idea and then you switched
over to the puppetry so what was the
transition from one to the other like it
was we just wanted to re-explore the
world of the Dark Crystal through
technology at broke you feel making
towards CGI and and stuff like that but
but you know the Hansen company they're
known for their puppets so it was never
we never we never said it's gonna be CG
it's gonna be animated there was just
you know there were so few ideas but but
you know obviously I came on because I
loved the original movie and I love
puppets and Netflix is the one that just
said you should make this series look as
much like the original movie as possible
and we were like you really you really
want to do that you really you're gonna
give us the resources to do that and we
were so we were shocked we were so happy
we were shocked and happy and in awe and
then we went about doing it we made the
show really I couldn't believe it when I
read the the CG thing I'm like no it's
not an option you can't do that how has
it been working on something that I mean
has been alive and thriving because of
the very dedicated fan base does that
kind of necessitate that you guys listen
to the fans and take some of their
opinions on this series into account
here you know what there's so many fans
involved with the show I mean even Taran
is a big fan you know we have fan we
have fans up and down the the crew of
the show our writers were tremendous
fans and Louie was a fan
you know we we've we had within our crew
people who had even one fan contest we
had people in one fan design contest one
of our script writers won the fan
fiction not fan fiction it was a a book
writing contest to write a why a book so
we had fan contest winners working on
our on our crew and it was let's hear
from one of our fans yeah I mean I I
have been enamoured of this story this
franchise since I was a young younger
boy than I am now since I was a kid and
I think what I found particularly
thrilling about the prospect of being
involved is that it is so faithful it is
it has that same kind of tactile quality
of the original movie it has that wait
we've used real puppets and built these
incredible environments I mean I haven't
personally but the team has and and I
think you know given the fact that the
Dark Crystal has such a dedicated core
fan base I think it needed to be done in
the spirit of the original movie there
are some exceptions and I hope it's not
demystifying things too much at the
points at which the storytelling demands
something that goes beyond the realm of
puppets there are some other techniques
employed to heighten and elevate things
but as a dedicated fan and as a purist
it only serves to enhance the story and
I think anyone who loved the original
movie will more than love this
there's working with the puppetry change
your job at all as far as work yes it
does
yes it really does and for me as an
actor and someone who really enjoys
voice work and has been involved in one
or two other animation projects it's a
really different challenge because you
have to match the rhythm of a very
gifted puppeteer but someone who has
their own character will take on the
role and I have to slot into that but
that's actually lovely and it's a
different challenge and it's more of a
symbiotic relationship so I'm only
responsible for really a part of the
performance there's a very very talented
puppeteer named Neil Sternberg who was
responsible for animating Rhiannon
it's I'm sorry to interrupt the with the
partnerships between the puppeteers and
the voice artists are pretty incredible
many times they they never met these
guys did meet but it ultimately every
performance is brought brought to life
by two people the person puppeteering
all the visual motion that you see and
they've actually put down the first pass
of the of the performance and then the
voice artist is so complimentary to that
that's that's one of the things I love
about filmmaking you know you it's it's
a bunch of different crafts coming
together to make something that they
couldn't do on their own you know if I'd
been the puppeteer behind Rihanna
it wouldn't have been very good try just
to see if you could do it no no I did I
did go and visit the set and I did go
and visit the workshop just because I
wanted to fanboy but no I never I never
got my my hands dirty as it were but I
did go and see things in their life it
was great what was it like seeing the
combined effort come together in the
final product it was there anything
about it that surprised you I mean I
think the scale of it surprised me I
knew I knew Louie I knew Louie's work I
obviously knew the Henson Company all of
the incredible things that it's done I
don't think I really appreciated quite
how epic it would feel and watching it
it really is quite extraordinary it's
really elevated and heightened and the
first movie is incredibly charming in
the de clever tricks it employs to give
it scale and to give it scope you know
so wide shots where you clearly have a
person running in costume you know the
great thing about making this in 2019 is
there's an extra 30 years of wisdom
involved in in storytelling so that the
the the things that are utilized to tell
that story are all the more complex and
sophisticated you bring up the way it
was shot I was curious about the
decision to stick with the Vista vision
on this one was that must when you
jumped into it what
yes I mean my goal and it's been and
literally yesterday again I was watching
the original movie and I really look at
the original movie look at our show look
at your movie and I just compare I've
been doing this for you know the last
eight years you've been working on this
just as close to the two you know Jim
Henson's vision and as possible and but
the tricks have changed you know puppets
are in the center and still you know the
lead characters of our show but
everything around these has changed so
so but it will feel exactly the same
just bigger you know more ample
exciting you know it's just it's it's
quite a different story the canvas is
much bigger but the feeling is the same
but you've also shot it so dynamically
you know Luiz an amazing director I'm
gonna speak for him that he's also
cameras he's also the camera made and
he's camera man he operates Steadicam he
he he operated Steadicam almost every
single day for 10 months on the show so
you know nobody can move the camera and
bring dynamism to puppets like he has
and you know we feel like we've never
seen puppets shot this way and I think a
lot of people are gonna watch the show
and forget that they're puppets
thank you very much say yes yes I shot
it differently because I just wanted to
you know bring it to today's audience
it's it's it's you know they're used to
puppets but we wanted to say you know
these puppets can compete with
superheroes hopefully I mean you know
you I know because I've seen things at
various stages of the process but I know
that we're an audience to see the
finished version there are so many
sequences in this where people will go
how on earth did they do that
yeah I mean I saw things at various
stages of development and you know I'd
be in there recording the voice might go
from a filmmaking perspective and the
techniques that Louie is employed but
also just on the expansion of the law
and the word of the film from a
character perspective from these these
creatures and these tribes things happen
in the story that as a fan gives you
that tingle up your spine oh that's cool
I mean the one I read ought to talk
about I'm in bar goat from talking about
so look to the talking points this
morning but there's things you go no
it's just so cool it's so simple it's in
camera as much as possible
ya know it's it's just it's exciting
hearing the way you guys describe it
because there's the built-in nostalgia
the fans that are gonna come back no
matter what but you have to capture the
the imagination of a younger generation
that's very much in line with a certain
type of content that we're getting all
the time and I imagine that must have
been a challenge to conceive of when
you're first putting this together
well the scripting is really good they
are direct our writers will Addison will
Matthews and Jeff added at asuri they're
their names but they actually really
wrote this as if it was people you know
they wanted to make sure that you were
in love with the heroes that you were
afraid for their lives when there was
danger and stakes and you know it is a
this really exciting storyline and a lot
of cliffhangers and you know it I don't
think we've never really had stories
like that to tell with puppets before
and I think even the first movie didn't
have the the stakes that this series has
there's so many untapped little corners
of that original movie I'm wondering
walking away from the original movie
were there any questions left in your
mind that you just were saying to
yourself I can't wait to tackle that and
flesh that out more in this series I
mean I think the route the the the great
thing effects making this series is the
Dark Crystal is a very micro cosmic look
at a very large world so it really feels
like it warrants this new chapter in the
story it's not like you know we've had
10 3-hour movies and we're eating out
juice from something that you know has
been spent a long time ago the beauty of
this is that the original movie deals
with
very few characters in a very very
specific time and you really feel the
history of what's happened hanging over
that movie so you're left with a million
questions and this series goes about
answering lots of them how do you
structure the very beginning of the show
because of course the movie it tees it
up with some text and it makes sure
everyone's caught up to speed
how do you make sure everybody's ready
for the series whether you're a fan or
newcomer the beauty the beauty of
working you know with you know in such a
big canvas ten episodes is that you can
actually take your time with the story
you'd have to say everything up front
introduce your characters slowly but
surely just make sure that people fall
in love with them really understand
their the problems the stakes everything
and that what that's really what Netflix
has given us because you know Lisa and I
have tried to put together a movie but
she's compressing so much story the
captain saying you know the rules of a
civilization they explain this in two
hours
ten episodes because we've created a
very very complex world now with seven
clans of gelfling they live all over
this land of thraw different
environments and it's big so you need
time and you need the you need the scope
of to be able to tell this whole story I
know a lot of people say that but but
shows but I'm showing I always get
confusing we always say the movie
because it's reads them it looks like
the movie and it's a ten hour movie
scatter cliffhangers between episodes
and you can watch two episodes or three
or four you can watch the whole thing it
just feels like one big story I have a
million questions but I got the wrap-up
sign so I want to toss it I want to toss
in what it does sound like Netflix was
very open and collaborative and this was
one heck of a thing to pull off with
them but was there any specific elements
of the show that either you were afraid
they would say or I got like too much
like rain this in a little bit we means
me I pushed it glass quite far you'll
see it's it's for children
adults will love it it's in the spirit
of the original movie I watched the Dark
Crystal I mean the movie came out in 82
right yeah
I wasn't born till 89 so I must have
seen it in about 95 but the thing that
was amazing about it is that it has a
kind of a thread of it's called the Dark
Crystal it has a thread of darkness that
runs through it it's it's totally
appropriate for children but there is
something challenging about it there's
something that feels a little bit
dangerous and dark about it and so it's
both satisfying for kids and grownups I
think and the series is absolutely in
the spirit of that I take all that thank
you guys thank you as I imagine many of
you are out there guys please do not
forget to like and share this episode
keep an eye out for Dark Crystal on
Netflix
August 30th August 30th countdown and
binge the entire show with us we will be
back real soon with more San Diego
comic-con coverage